Sister Wives star Christine Brown
celebrates her birthday eating nachos
with her new fiance which some fans
think is a dig at her ex Cody I never
look back I just started moving forward
Christine turned 51 Tuesday and her Beau
David Wooley celebrated with a sweet
post featuring pics of her and a large
plate of nachos he sweetly writes happy
birthday I love eating nachos with you
my queen the birthday girl shared the
same snaps thanking him for the fun
nacho date and adding I feel blessed to
have someone to laugh with he's
wonderful and romantic and so kind and
everything I've been looking for sure
they're lovey-dovey posts but some fans
notice a shady undertone aimed at Cody
why well in 2012 he wrote in the
family's Memoir becoming Sister Wives
about a moment early in his relationship
with Christine that made him question
his attraction to her after he saw her
get this eating nachos this is an
experience for me that is my life and
I'm kind of bearing my guts and I know I
feel like my job is to be truthful Cody
wrote In the book I hate myself for the
thoughts I had at that moment but the
sight of this chubby girl in my car
devouring chili cheese nachos for
breakfast put the breaks on our
relationship the nacho experience cooled
my attraction a little well a lot
blaming me for me being turned off by
your behavior fast forward to 2021 and
their dwindling physical connection
played a big role in Christine ending
their 25-year spiritual marriage
true
that I wasn't attracted to you anymore
I'm not interested in Intimate marriage
with you anymore to hear that he wasn't
attracted to me it was terrible to hear
and it's super embarrassing right I just
got to thinking you know what
it really just goes both ways I really
just wasn't attracted I'm not going to
keep fighting for this I'm not going to
keep trying and I'm not going to keep
doing this if you're not attracted to me
what is it you're looking for in a new
partner kindness
um real just kindness and romantic
relationship for sure someone's who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that one of the kids told me dad mom
says you have your soul mate
and she wants hers well I hope she finds
her soul mate and Christine's bound just
that in David just he's absolutely a
dream come true after four months of
dating the lovebirds revealed they're
engaged that's more like a personal
strength that I feel like I have more
than I've ever felt before because I was
able to make steps for my future and for
my present and so I just feel more
confident as well yeah it seems
Christine's found her partner in life
and in nachos
foreign